okay I'm to this video playing my old
nemesis what a gas here he goes again 25
20 and unfortunately as I mentioned a
number of times this is non increment
chest so he is very liable to to play
rook against your gets tough sell let's
see what happens we have from Kings
Indian I was wanted to try something new
I played with 97 and not with a quickie
fight because he always plays them the
exchange variation and this is not not a
terribly great line but it is some a
line that is very liable to lead to two
very dry plate which he of course excels
and he just wants to trade everything
down at win on time that this man
getting game plan so let's see what
happens here now this that's interesting
at least an enterprising tribe you
should I take it not sure yeah c6 is the
threat I'm not sure can i play but
should be seven simply maybe I'm just
counter-attacking 1.e4 yes we can tell
my queen side structure though that was
a good play
I really don't mind this style of
playing is so playing a very technical
chess which is perfectly okay if you go
for those kind of phone yeah slightly
better positions and trying to grind out
wins I only feel that you should
sometimes just play it just accept that
rook against rookies draw okay so let's
see what should i do here yeah that's
not really convenient this is six move
okay if you take say I'm going to take a
form that's not great but it's a
slightly problematic yeah my light
squares are very weak why the sun is
better here yeah probably be six wasn't
wasn't the brightest idea
okay 287 where to a 397 to a 3
they probably wants to play rock do one
with the temple no
yeah white is slightly better there's no
question so now just rudely aight i
guess now i can also go rookie to d7 I
don't so let's see ya bye now I have a
bath a F equalized him there's nothing
nothing going on really besides the fact
that it's it's a suspiciously smelling
like one of those dead end games
you have trying to play quickly I mean I
know what's what what what would happen
at the end
yeah maybe you can avoid the rook trade
yeah maybe I know a key really cannot
have rocketed to Roxy one is not not an
especially great idea I came and take
him check
okay let's see yeah 94 looks very very
equal I scott e 560 but I can come on
sony no use the only idea left here is
of course to attack f7 or f2 for both
sides so um this is what still is in the
position thinking about d3 a.m. maybe
this is the easiest yeah probably it is
getting to to the pawn him
yeah I'd like to get the Bishop to c5
but at the moment I don't see how I may
accomplish that
I can you worked it to air that's yeah
but still I mean it's totally dead wow
so is going to the playing on time
routine really early time warning check
check
draw our third yeah this guy is such a
complete idiot yeah it's unbelievable
and he's not even really quick yeah yeah
yeah it is obviously has lots of time on
his hands I see is playing on this this
crap all the time draw a hand drawn and
now it's a repetition em yeah really
completely sick yeah um not much to tell
I mean as usual he got a good very good
advantage but he very often does not
even try to win it on position he just
wants to play this dead positions on
time and around here I feel like I mean
really I'm in trouble I mean does this
must be good for what he's got the
bishop pair and those weaknesses so he
does this was nicely played probably I
let see this was interesting be 65 was
interesting I'm not sure this assistant
isn't ideal but I didn't find a better
solution in the
that I had available yay around here
white is still somewhat better but this
was some simply not not forceful enough
was basically just marking time doing
nothing yeah okay this is to totally
totally equal check now that's that's
even debatable if I should do that i
mean but it should it is just a draw
what can you do the idea at least
thought rook t2 i mean trying for
whatever but ok here it's simply nothing
to talk about alright thanks for
watching